hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay this guy
watched his wannabe girlfriend jump off
a roof very sad but he avenged her I
don't even know what my objective I
haven't had an objective this entire
game so I I don't know why they'd give
me one now I guess I go through the
doors in the park or something I don't
know I need some morphine
hold on monsters don't mob me just yet I
need morphine yeah hello anybody
anybody that's not it
I guess I guess I could go back to black
him there were other routes going around
maybe I didn't even need to see Sophie
kill herself I don't know
okay music cut out loading
oh you here we flocked it was not
okay now I'm just going backwards
backtracking right shouldn't be anywhere
to go tell me what to do it struck me
hey deal training Amy I don't know the
old trading hubby rifle rounds loadout
up whip it out be all prepared like oh
no oh oh no I was supposed to go to
Sophie's body of course I'm an idiot I'm
an idiot guys I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
idiot I know you were all probably
screaming that's why her body was still
there I don't need to save all right Oh
Sophie I mean let me go I'll involved I
love yourself you have to leave please
let me go Simon good okay
I was weird maybe Simon's a creeper in
real life chapter 4 I got the key card
okay that's right
so I did need to see Simon done so in
his fantasies acting out his own
rejection which is like really sad I
just got to be also pretty sad okay gown
I'm ready for some more scares I
shouldn't ask that
I got a gun why did she have a key part
to TL trading a B whatever that is go
through into the devil hmm door won't
open
it's so strange it's quiet too quiet
so dark or jam or giving me unique
door not opening dialogue who's there
huh really is eerily quiet huh that's
not happening
freaking me out okay anymore anyone else
run so tough huh hey
did I not fair why do they get gun I
guess I got a gun so give is it out so
tough you take home bullets I tell you
you son of a shotgun up in this [ __ ]
[Music]
shotgun Oh what's down there we go head
blows oh okay they drop their guns okay
I need to pick up their ammo okay yeah
okay now I got tons of piss
cool I've also got tons of shotgunner oh
you cuz if they're gonna give me pistol
and lotion don't even try it buddy
that's it
bunny with a hardness events and legal
advice we will protect you that's my
best Swedish accent don't judge me he
will protect you who's here early heard
of down into these somebody
we'll protect you from the low that's my
there there's my play the fuse here fuse
fuse you up don't trip on the darn
stairs what am i doing there's illegally
advice
we will chat you have with all Hough
debased ah there we go legal counselor
and we're gonna tote is wanna mess with
me not even a little bit of a threat how
was that oh so bad why don't I get a
hammer I think a hammer would be better
than my lost baton that I don't have
anymore
whoa whoa what the heck ah
I think my games bug um Wow holy crap
some some bad happen
Wow something talking to hopefully maybe
that'll get me out of there cuz
something went wrong nope
okay my game bugged out hardcore so I'll
be right back in a bit yeah in a bit
how do everybody we're back good thing I
tapped that safe because I was able to
come back break reload where I was
going going going going
[Music]
all right I gotta cut it here thanks so
much for watching see you in the next
part
markiplier out